you know what's [ __ ] funny though when
we everytime I meet somebody everybody
think I'm hello oldest [ __ ] they're like
how old are you like you're 40 right
give me oxidized I'll tell you like 85
some Dragon year - dragon [ __ ] Yeah
right mr. zodiac over here you know yeah
well in five four three two one
welcome everybody to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we got some
very very special guests if you've been
in the hip-hop scene and if you're Asian
and you don't know who these
[ __ ] are you're a dumb [ __ ]
and I don't like your face very much and
you were a mistake when you were born so
fun with dumb what's up everybody we're
finally here we finally me man yeah I've
been I've actually knew about your music
for quite a while right and then you
guys recently had a huge resurgence yeah
we did how the [ __ ] did that happen just
because you guys have I mean I feel like
anybody who listened to any any type of
hip-hop that any Asian people did they
knew who you work for sure for sure then
out of nowhere out of the blue your your
[ __ ] too started to blow the [ __ ] up out
of nowhere right right we had a few
resurgence is you know we had a few of
them yeah we had a few resurgence is you
know this couch is too comfy right now
while wax we just we moved to LA about
seven months ago
okay that's recent it was recent is my
second time coming to LA you know it's
my first time coming with my partner my
riot partner excuse me Jael over here
and yes we've been incubating in her
house for about seven months just
stacking songs and just kind of getting
ideas together and I think the
resurgence you're talking about is maybe
like three years ago when we had that
viral on Facebook Omar recently like
like maybe three years ago two three
years like something blew the [ __ ] and
then you guys were everywhere the seven
rings happened you know and then uh this
platform called tbp shout out
teambackpack
on Facebook you know the huge platform
and yeah one of the I think their
caption was G's North Koreans go crazy
or something like that you know
people people clicked on it just to see
like what the [ __ ] are they talking
about because these Koreans go ham on a
beat or sometimes just something like
that back then
yeah the caption was like Kim Jong moon
or some crazy [ __ ] yeah so that was
definitely uh and when that happened we
caught the eyes of some people out here
in LA our management company shout out
to them and then they brought us out
here so yeah and now we just feel like
yo let's go all in you know last Sarat I
feel [ __ ] man
so prior to that video popping up yeah
what were you guys doing with your
career we you know when I was in New
York this happened when I was in New
York jocks was not an entity yet you
know I was just up there we were
actually a trio before cuz you you know
manifests I don't know if you were like
they were kind of a duo first and I kind
of like tagged along right right right
and then man II ended up getting married
and exact a drama you know but I was in
New York just kind of coasting you know
I was figuring out I you were both
originally from Virginia and Virginia's
very static in a way you know like yeah
the art scene and the music scene it was
kind of like we were waiting for
opportunities to happen for doors to
open but we you know I had this epiphany
just like nah man you know I'm not
getting younger I look at my I look at
the mirror look like I just [ __ ] every
day you know so I'm like let's go to New
York let's go all out I started working
at s Obie's and then I invited this guy
out and was like yay let's just make a
song just kind of like let's let's do
something outside of her style and try
to blow people away you know and that
became something we had we had been in
New York I had kept visiting from
Virginia I was going back and forth yeah
for like a couple months we were just
making a bunch of songs and kind of
releasing them as JL and lyrics and then
that's the one we kind of put out and
then a couple months after we put it out
Rick had met the guy from teambackpack
yeah and then he happened to put it out
and did the thing and it was just the
alignment of stars David you know like
yeah we put that out a couple months ago
there was not much traction because
honestly our reach was just our Facebook
friends list you know like our Instagram
following list but when they put it on
that platform the shares went crazy so
people
from like you know our past from people
that knew me from my you know the
beautiful cycle days they all kind of
saw us on the newsfeed and then they
were just like wow they're back you know
and then the wildfire happened and yeah
man the rest was history ever since that
[ __ ] crazy how that [ __ ] works out
still exciting because I mean I always
say this too it's like sometimes I meet
some of the most talented people right
right but they just haven't had that one
hit yeah and that's all you [ __ ] need
sometimes it's like and at that point
like how hard is it to be resilient to
say like yo I know I'm good at this [ __ ]
yeah like this is what I was [ __ ]
born to do I've been doing this is day
[ __ ] one right my [ __ ] due respect
and you just grind and grind fine and
then out of nowhere boom something
happens especially with your Korean
parents you know of course did you know
he was about to yeah you told your dad
right you're like well yeah like I was
at that time so I had been in New York
for a couple months visiting and then
like I lived there on his couch for a
couple months and then I was like on my
way back to Virginia Beach because my
parents own clothing stores so I'm gonna
be like alright I'm ready to put the rap
[ __ ] aside I'm gonna help you take over
so my dad could eventually you know
retire and [ __ ] exactly then that night
as I'm driving down that's when I see
the view start to jump up and it in like
like every refresh is a hundred thousand
more you know every refresh is like
twelve twelve hours we reached like a
million on Facebook so he told his dad
never mind you know actually I gotta go
back exactly and that's when we decided
to like really become a duo and then you
know ta hit us up and then we kind of
how did that feel
oh man that felt in crime een but even
that like a million views how do you
translate to your parents you know
they're like so what yeah like where's
the money what's going on you know so
the recognition felt good also just that
feeling of like damn what I'm doing is
not futile you know like I still have it
I still have the attention two years and
these guys are still willing to listen
to me so it does definitely lit a fire
under but you know for sure and then
when we got that call from TA
we were all actually
celebrating in the sops office Oso B's
is a hip-hop Club out there in New York
legendary right so we were over there I
was doing graphic design downstairs and
we got the call Phil who was the one
that directed seven rings from no ledge
productions jail and I we were all just
huddled together just like oh my god is
this crazy refresh another hundred
refresh we were just yeah man and then I
get a call um I don't know it was a
cellphone office phone whatever it was
but it was Kevin ish dumbfounded and Pro
from ta yeah and you're like what up you
know we see we see we see something's
happening right now you know we should
talk and then bla bla bla things move
and I told them I was like girl it was
weird because you know they wanted to
they wanted to manage me lyrics and
because we were celebrating as a trio at
the time something in my heart was like
I don't want to abandon this right now
you know I feel like this is just
something here there's something that he
could bring to the table that I can and
vice versa you know there was a gay
Union contrast type of feel you know I
feel like more than a more than his solo
group I felt like the duo would be a
stronger hit you know yeah
and ta just thankfully they just they
thought about it and they sat on it and
they agreed and yeah man we moved out to
California we drove to California five
days you'd roll because we needed a car
out here you know we had to drive out
here we need content out of it though
cuz we were at that time we were putting
together a lot of content for this
writer doing
yeah worked out it was cool I mean and
also you know you know that thing before
you get married or before you start just
matrimony or like a relationship you
have to go cross country that's what I
heard but it's like before you're like I
were like a partnership we're like a
team that cross country is like one of
those prerequisites you have to do just
be like okay we're not gonna kill each
other you know what I mean yeah yeah you
know it was good man so prior to you
guys moving I mean what was the working
relationship like was it very loose like
you guys do you guys kind of saw each
other every now and then when you want
it to work right it was like did that
happen what happened is I ended up
moving to New York like kind of like
here to open room in his spot so like I
I'm gonna move in
living room yeah yeah [ __ ] but then I
got the room to you oh yeah yeah yeah
then I say you know we stayed out there
for a while but then the thing about
getting that viral hit is after that you
have to follow it up it's me up exactly
the sophomore jinx TARDIS one yeah and
then what should you know cuz after we
felt that that surge and then like you
know the second one comes out it's not
as not as you know viral is not as
popping but we felt like we really had
to follow it up
we still had we still had to hunger we
still had the vision but at that time it
was so we hit this plateau we were kind
of like okay let's make songs you know
let's try to stay relevant but at that
time you know cuz I was in New York I
was straight depletion mode you know my
my income wasn't as as much as what I
was spending so I was worried about real
life problems bills and all that so one
day jail came to let's just let's let's
do like the old times and just make a
track you know and let's make a video
for it
and yeah man that that really this is to
all you guys mad like any any of you
guys that are going to this just like
uncertain times it's just just doing it
you know just deciding to just [ __ ]
put something out there also if you
[ __ ] suck just give up I want to be a
Calvin Klein model she's gonna work out
I'll still pursuing that [ __ ] what would
have happened this damn [ __ ] happens
dude that's [ __ ] crazy man yeah you
know what's interesting though like I
feel like I mean this is just me from
personally listening to all the tracks
that you're putting out you guys are
putting out like decent content
consistently yeah which how the [ __ ] do
you do that that's so [ __ ] hard man
right right but how the [ __ ] do you do
that
the thing is between the time after cuz
after New York we kind of moved back to
Virginia where we were waiting to move
out here that that took like a longer
than we expected so we're just kind of
waiting in Virginia we didn't really
make much for almost like a year so so
you know we kind of came here and we're
like I [ __ ] we just got a stack up
exactly mad content as things got pushed
back and you know inevitably things get
delayed you know so like our scheduling
got delayed our move to Cali got delayed
a little bit but we took advantage of
that time to just stock up usually we
would be so giddy to release something
so we'll drop will like mix something
down and drop it that day you know but
yeah our mentality was like yo let's
just store some ammunition it's good
you clips fool you know so we get out
there and we get the we get the
equipment we get the support we get the
push from our machine then we'll have
like product to push you know yeah so
yeah I think we did the right thing
we could have easily came out here and
just put out stuff and scattered it but
we wanted we wanted to really we weren't
ready to just come out to the west coast
and be like okay this is what the yaksas
you know we had to we had to live here
we had to situate ourselves acclimate
ourselves and now we feel like okay we
have the right to kind of just drop so
every week every Friday 6:00 p.m. for
the next couple of months and we're
you're gonna expect something new from
the ox' we just try so tonight as we got
something yeah but [ __ ] that's crazy to
me man like I feel like just because you
know being an artist and telling
somebody to do thing on a time schedule
is very difficult true you know when we
were you know back in then when I was
doing used to consistently that was so
[ __ ] hard man I had to put these
videos and help him I didn't like them
all right you know yeah cuz how like it
was just me talking [ __ ] and most the
time I'm a pretty happy guy you were
super consistent with it bro that was
nuts and then I lost my [ __ ] mind and
I quit you two years that's got a [ __ ]
uber I mean it helps for us cuz he's
doing the editing of the videos you know
we got a shooter that's kind of just
coming along with us some shooting shots
every every other day or something so
like you know he's really putting in the
work to get that edit done every week
too so we both put a good you know we
know our roles now out here in LA that's
crazy man I like I it's interesting when
somebody gets that that second push man
yeah and it's like I'm gonna I'm gonna
shift over like this cuz I feel that I
don't know
[ __ ] funny right now usually in that
chairs of Winnie the Pooh doll and dress
she was like you don't deserve this [ __ ]
here you don't respect them this podcast
is brought to you by Sunday scary Sunday
scary's if you already don't know is the
leader is a huge leader in the CBD space
CBD for those of you who don't know is
an amazing amazing thing to have in your
life for me personally I know that a lot
of people don't know about this but I
actually have a bit of anxiety and I
have a little trouble just learning how
to relax here and there
CBD specifically like CBD gummies that I
take help me to relax a lot I actually
use it before I go spar and I train
because it kind of gets me in the right
headspace and it really just gets me
outside of my head no psychoactive
effects with certain CBDs if they don't
have THC in it so if you guys are
worried about that just you don't have
to be worried about it it just really
helps calm your nerves and for me
personally it's it's one of those things
that I I take quite frequently it just
it's it's it's amazing man it really
does help out with a lot of stuff
not only does help out with like like
anxiety issues and actually helps me
calm down before I go to sleep as well
so if you haven't had CBD products and
you're um you don't know what it is give
it a try nothing's gonna happen it's
it's it's a really really really good
thing to have specifically in your
pantry like right before you go to sleep
or any time that you feel like you're
feeling nervous or you know you just you
just not in the right headspace CBD
products can help you well and Sunday
scary's they got your back baby so check
it out get 50% off with code brain at
Sunday scary's calm my friends and stop
dreading the everyday BS in life that
doesn't actually matter remember to get
15% off use code brain at Sunday scary's
dot-com so yeah I mean
because everyone well uh what year did
you start like when was your first video
the weight loss video will remember what
year that was
which way allows me to cut wonderful
times that I failed
you know what pissed me off though is
why I would do this weight loss [ __ ]
right right and then I would go on these
shows and I would lose like ten pounds
right and then maybe I'll gain back
twenty if somebody meets me and they go
bro can I tell you something I actually
lost a hundred pounds and you've
inspired me you know so I
I only recently lost the weight like
maybe a year and a half ago me bro you
looking good so I'm trying to you know I
just eating like a normal human being
man I would eat like I would literally
eat like I'm going to the electric chair
tomorrow bro everyday talk to him
and that's exactly what I mean like last
meal like last meal like I like the
quantity you know what happens like cuz
I grew up so [ __ ] broke right like I
don't know what an appetizer was right
you know usually when said cash starts
to flow in it's like oh I could try this
try that
I knew my Korean parents are like make
sure you finish everything so I bet
she's beaten inside me yeah so it's like
left what the [ __ ] are left over I'm
the exact same way I like if you go to a
Korean restaurant with me all the punch
on jerk we call him Justin PPO he puts
all the ppl means mix and then just mix
it all but one last bite I felt the meal
was incomplete unless I had for those
silver rice bowls bro you know Roy Choi
chef Roy Choi he calls me MC for bops
because when I went to his Korean
restaurant pot at the Lion Hotel like I
I eat everything he brought out like
click cleaned it you know I mean Africa
style cleaned it a four bops
and yeah I could eat more like that's
that was a thing but rice is my vice so
I can say stay away from my [ __ ] right
so like if I had there's no way I could
eat one bowl of [ __ ] rice that's like
tell me to eat one taco it's one Pringle
you can't do that yeah because our
[ __ ] punch on tell it Josh so they
set me up for [ __ ] failure right you
know it's weird too because Korean
parents had this weird habit of calling
you a fat [ __ ] but then ask you why
you're not eating
yeah [ __ ] is that my mom would literally
she would do that she'll do this Thanks
give me two when I go back to Sacramento
good you know I'll sit there and then
she'll be happy that I lost this weight
cuz I'm healthier right yeah and then
I'll sit there and be like I'm done with
this food that she'll be like what's
wrong with my food literally called me a
fat [ __ ] 30 years what are you saying
right now and there she'll be mad then
I'll eat it this years my dad would do
the same thing he'd be like you know the
dangers of ramen and how much you
shouldn't and why he's cracking around
me my parents used to do this [ __ ] that
I used to stand a bit about it but
Korean parents are one of the only
parents that will sock you in the mouth
and ask you why you're crying my dad has
stalked me in the face and be like yeah
well you cry yeah hit me and be like you
know why right now the mental yo they
used to do you have parents I used to
hit themselves like you're doing this to
me so crazy my dad used to do this other
[ __ ] where he would take his fist I'll
go and then I would have to punch my
disrespect and then he did that to me
too but you'd have to train where you
come in hard and then so funny dude like
people don't realize like how bad like
Korean parents would be to share their
sons oh they didn't give a [ __ ] I once
got beat so bad I couldn't go to school
for a week and I thought that was just
normal like my dad beat my ass so hard
both my ass cheeks turned purple damn
and I could have sit in a chair right
and so I was like and when I got older I
was like yo was the worst thing you got
hit with you remember oh man I got hit
by everything ah let's see this let's go
down the category you know what the
thing I hated the most actually I'm not
sure if you guys got hit by the [ __ ]
uh-huh but you know those little green
bamboo sticks that used to hold up
plants
oh yeah I called that [ __ ] the [ __ ]
silent but deadly brawls
you know why just it was you could hear
it cuz the wisp but it was so fast you
can see it it was like your ass beat by
a ghost right I call it the delay too
because they would whip I hit my back
and I'm like you don't feel it that
bamboo stick comes under the same family
as a radio antenna yes like ripping off
that I love you customers I love
customers
yeah do both your parents do a dry
cleaning well my own clothing stores for
sure but I clean his [ __ ] my dad was uh
when I was younger my dad was just
Hubble me he was a master like a tech
window man oh [ __ ] so he wouldn't he
wouldn't physically as my heat and like
there's a couple times where he might
have done it like a spinning back-kick
mound there's more of like like a do
push-ups for like 30 minutes and have
your feet up right paying or like oh my
god did you have to do the [ __ ] Seymour
oh yeah yeah oh yeah the remote control
the two remote controls man Korean
people punish their children the most
creative [ __ ] man
yeah like I remember this one time like
I I got caught cheating in school and so
my teacher called my parents and I
remember I went to the white lady right
like you you don't grow up in a Korean
household that's like I beg you don't
tell my parents don't tell my parents is
a life and that's interesting was like I
didn't realize that she wasn't white her
last name is Escobar she's Mexican but
she doesn't speak Spanish right and so
she don't give a [ __ ] people are just
another version of Korean people 100%
okay and so I was like I beg you please
don't tell me she goes David I have to
do it when I got home she had I to do
this [ __ ] right I get on my knees I had
to hold this I remember it was this
green plastic chair like this and then
if it dropped down it was so heavy it
was smashed my hair because it smashed
my head and I dropped my head and my dad
would hit
huge lump on my head and a huge bucket
on my ass
that's nice we're ruthless dude let me
ask you now because my parents - you
know shoutout to my parents they were
very yeah they were very physical back
then but are they now soft he's now or
what
no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] man oh she's so
funny though but me and my mom were like
best friends we get along very well but
she's always been an extreme lady my
father's a pastor dude so really he's a
pastor we own a beauty supply store - so
so my mom has gotten more and more
intense as the years has gone by and she
was crazy enough as as when we were kids
I got so many stories about my mom so
she's Manning the the beauty supply
store and my dad so my dad would do that
and and run a church at the same time
that's awesome so like my you get the
ratchet girls in there like well we have
a store it's like it's like a hood
clothing - it's like our clothes so you
know I mean same customer base yeah yeah
you know what the funny [ __ ] - I used to
stand a bit about like because when I
used to run that stores a black bee
supply store right and like fat chunk of
my friends are black so people would
come to this store I used to get so mad
because when when customer would steal
[ __ ] yeah right it's because I'm black
on my first of all it's a black beauty
supply store everybody's [ __ ] you saying
right now you would play the race card
yeah you can't see the customer next
year we're cool they're not stealing
[ __ ] are you saying I don't I don't
condone violence at all but I do you
know this might be inconvenient it might
be like unpopular thought but you know
you see these videos now we're like you
know the asian beauty store owners like
actually fighting the like they did lose
it now and then see them just like
getting into fights
yeah is that does that what does that
feel you know what it is though for me
like the reason why I have a hard time
feeling hard for those peoples because
my parents have been through that - yeah
but it never got it up it never got to
that point mind you my parents have been
spit on they've been kicked my my our
windows have been shattered people have
[ __ ] us up my father was also a pastor
so he's also very loving yeah so he
can't blame individual problems - a
whole culture Wow so my dad's just like
that's that crazy person okay
19 I say 95% of the customers are really
cool exactly but you got to realize -
these stores that we have that a Korean
beauty supply stores are also put in
very bad neighborhoods ya know what I
mean so the if let's say it was a beauty
supply store out in Ladera heights it's
not gonna be like that you know what I
mean but because they're in like a lot
of disenfranchised areas and these
there's a reason why these stores are
there there's a there's a chance that
this might happen you can't go into an
area where this where this is a problem
they spent not this [ __ ] not to happen
right it's a part of owning these
businesses so when these things happen
yeah my mom has been my mom has flipped
out a few times you know she's trying to
grab customers from stealing you know
like a [ __ ] maniac she would never do
that and I would have to she would even
tell me to calm down when I get angry
because I see people spit on my parents
face but actually I have to bring it
down there and be like or even just
verbally like you mean did they say some
hard [ __ ] to all this race is she [ __ ]
you know but then at the same time I'm
just like well forgive them they do not
know what they forgive them or I'll pray
to God that when they walk out God you
sent a truck evil dude but I've kind of
learned to like understand and it's not
giving people a pass for bullying my
parents issue
we're like if my parents can tell me I
can do it too then right so I've my dad
understands it's like those are this
those people yeah everybody else is
really cool and when they when when the
good customers are around they see that
they stop a mill exactly sure you know
there's good ones out there first
majority them are great sort of small
percentage and that's the same for us -
like we got a lot of [ __ ] trashy-ass
Korean people yeah oh yeah but you know
media doesn't blow up our trashy-ass
Korean people you know like in our
culture - I mean if we want to talk
about it like Korean men business men
they consistently cheat on their wives
all the [ __ ] time and it's just kind
of swept under the table yeah but we're
not considered pieces to talk about it
so in that culture like how's your
culture and all that you know
Namah shout out to your fares s that's
true yeah yeah and you know when I see
that too like I I do see a glimpse of my
parents but my father would never go out
and do that [ __ ] because he's smarter
than that yeah you know what I mean he's
smarter he goes Joe if I put my hands on
this lady the only thing that happens is
that I look bad right right so why would
I even go and do that you know there's a
history between like asian and black
people too that you have to be very
aware of right course that Wesley out
here especially out here dude I mean we
talked about the [ __ ] riots
right you know I mean we talk about that
latashia harmless when she got shot and
killed by the Korean store there is this
history of like Ice Cube yeah there's
like there's like this weird like
relationship that people don't really
understand you know and how I always
explain it to for people when they talk
about like the the asian and black
community thing it's like when asian
immigrants come to this country we have
no notion of what america is that back
in the day right right so the stuff that
is fed to immigrants or what people feed
to us and we don't speak english and so
and and people are like well why do
certain asian people feel this way this
is what we were fed this is what we were
told hundred percent that's it and as
they get older they start to learn they
understand and they get better from this
stuff right so and then on top of that
too there's this idea of like well asian
people come into black neighborhoods in
me and they kind of like exploit or
exploit us it's like well hold on it for
a second hey my parents aren't the
reason why your parents couldn't get a
loan to open up a business we don't know
that [ __ ] they just saw our little
cheeky gucci eyes and they're like hey
[ __ ] you're gonna be alone we're gonna
make sure that you're gonna open up in
this business center we don't know about
these things yeah cuz there was a issue
on Twitter recently where this girl was
talking about hey don't buy your black
beauty solutions or chinks or whatever
right and you know people are like yet
the system is set for Korean people to
make sure that we can't own [ __ ] like
we'll hold on for a second you're
blaming these 70 year old Korean
business owners and came to this country
with zero [ __ ] dollars there's no the
language didn't know the language so
they could only get supplies from people
who spoke Korean they don't know the
backend story of people they owned it oh
they're only choosing to give it to
Korean people right if you want to get
mad at somebody get mad at those people
business owners they don't know the [ __ ]
they they didn't know that we were so
poor we're making 25 grand a [ __ ]
year supporting four people in the
family you know and I see people walking
in with Jordans they're walking with all
this [ __ ] exactly and they go look at
you rich Asians like the Jordans are too
prideful to take welfare so where does
that leave us so it was like this weird
dynamic where I I felt like there was
such a huge misunderstanding it's like
you know you're mad you're mad at us and
we're just confused we don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on right you want to
be mad at people be mad at individuals
don't don't be mad at a whole cult right
right that's what I really don't like
cuz we could pick apart every single
culture and pick what we don't like and
focus on that the whole time for sure
the only people that were allowed to
really joke about and race and cultures
[ __ ] white people just because they
say like oh why people are this doesn't
change the fact that you own everything
doesn't change the fact that you're
running you're winning so there's really
no hate or any type of feeling behind it
so sometimes when I see like a couple of
white people like why you always doing
white jokes it's because it doesn't
affect your culture yeah if I say like
look at look at the white guy and his
Wonder Bread you know what the [ __ ]
right you know like what does that
really mean we just we're trying to make
fun of something at least exactly you
know it's just a weird dynamic that I've
always had to deal with and just to be
safe we just make fun of ourselves man
you know I make fun of all cultures
right I make fun of Chinese people
within these people right people Korean
people I roast great people the most and
the Korean people hate that yeah it's
the Don Rickles this podcast is brought
to you by native my friends have you
used deodorants and products that have
all this weird gunky stuff that you just
don't want in there all native has none
of that my friends and what I mean by
that let me just get into the specifics
all right first of all when you hear
about these products sometimes you
wonder like is it going to work though
all these products that say that they
don't have certain things like do they
really work specifically their
deodorants well native does work because
I have native deodorants and I use it
that cucumber mint my friends oh that
smells so good people sometimes they
come up to me and they're like yo what's
that what's that fresh cologne or or
detergent that you have - I know you got
a completely wrong man that's that
cumber mint dieldrin I've been using
from native men and let me get into the
specifics all right
people love it they have over 8,000
five-star reviews you could check them
out they've been on the Today Show Elle
magazine PopSugar refinery29
just to name a few they use ingredients
that you know less is more with native
they have fewer simple increases so you
know everything that's in there
deodorant it's worth it
native my friends is also aluminum free
it's safe and effective without parabens
and talc really really cool so if you're
worried about that stuff native has none
of it man there's a no risk to try it
out either they offer free returns and
exchanges in the u.s.a so check this out
for 20% off your first purchase visit
native deodorant calm and use promo code
gb during the checkout once again for
20% off your first purchase visit native
deodorant calm and use promo code gb
during your checkout to cop some native
deodorant today it's funny because like
i sometimes i get people from korea who
will write these long diatribes in
korean they think I can't read Korean I
could read it it's mad at me they're
just like oh you don't know Korean
culture how dare you think about Korean
people this way like Korean people
aren't that I'm like bro I'm talking
about Korean American culture right
different from what what else from the
cost of pandu up from from Korea yeah
they're like you make Korean people look
buy suck my dick suck my [ __ ] oh my
god that's all another thing that's a
whole different culture those those the
Koreans that are over there obviously
especially when it comes to music to
know yeah the hip hop over there is
popping now too but it's just like it's
different from what we have to go
through as Korean Americans here 100%
we got people over there in Korea if
they have think tanks or like these
these diese you know management's they
just sit down in a room look at watch
YouTube videos of what's popping now you
know so aesthetically to get their
braids they get the to get the dreads
they have already talked ones now
they're Rascals and all that and we get
the butt end of the cultural
appropriation conversation you gotta
mean like the ones actually yeah like
this is what I actually grew up with and
over there we got people braiding their
hairs without even understanding like
you know I'm Tomba but yeah I know what
you mean how do you guys feel about that
[ __ ]
it's like cuz you guys have been on the
scene and you've been rapping for so
long
yeah and then you have some of these
people that come out of rap Hogg ones
which is like rap [ __ ] what did you
call that [ __ ] it's not a class yes it's
crazy because I come from the era where
when we started rapping or like we're in
the room like trying to record our
parents are like yeah what the [ __ ] are
you doing you know study right but now
because they see shows like show me the
money and they see like some kids yeah
their hands are just like you alright
a16 go practice your rap
all right same thing but but then you
know when that happens I guess you know
this is kind of like this is the pure
side of me it's like when you don't have
that factor against you I don't think
that you want it as much do you know
what I mean you're given and the road is
less there's less turbulence on there so
it's like it's kind of more it's it's
smoother and in that way I don't think
that you can reach like some of the
levels that we have that we that we had
to go through you know this might be
like an old head thinking but I do I do
think that I don't think that's like an
old head thing I think that's an artist
thing right because you always want
things to come from a very real place
and yeah if it doesn't come from a real
place you could [ __ ] feel yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know I mean with the
Korean hip-hop I take it more sonically
and like musically they're not to make
music you know I'm sure it's just you
know there's not much like influence or
not really anything back in there you
know not even not even culture or like
nationality going into it we come from
the era where our lyricism was lyricism
was awesome
you know like that the heavier the more
sustenance you had the more like
realness or content that you had into
music that was like people looked up to
that you know yeah nowadays if you if
you're too lyrical or too you know multi
syllabic then you're kind of considered
a nerd you know like a rapper rapper
yeah so it's a whole different it's a
whole different era where you kind of
have to find your find your place my
name is lyrics oh yeah
don't give a [ __ ] about lyrics right now
you know hope but it's interesting
though because I think there's a
resurgence going back towards more like
hip hop 1% because we've been seeing cuz
that [ __ ] right there it's it's not a
gimmick like I you know what actually
music is like it's like a buffet you get
to pick and choose what you like and so
sometimes when I hear people talk about
hip hop and mind you I was on the side
to where I was like yo like this [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] real hip-hop yeah what
really what is real hip-hop right it all
comes from somewhere right right and
everybody can pick and choose what they
want now what I do disagree with is how
long will your sound last mmm longevity
longevity is what I'm thinking about
right because at the end of the day
people who do consume hip-hop I think
they are looking for something they want
to feel something yeah no you know cuz
we talk about like for example like when
Jay Cole and like Kendrick came on the
scene that [ __ ] made me feel good for
sure like I'm not not even as somebody
who likes that type of music I could
understand what they're saying right
like here's my [ __ ] about Jay Cole Jay
Cole talks about not going on but the
father and then I'm like damn I know
what you feel but that's that's that's
what I like about music is specifically
hip-hop it could take you to this story
for sure you know and sometimes to like
I get really frustrated with people when
they talk about music here's something I
[ __ ] name um scrounge my gears that's
what grinds my gears they have an album
drops mmm right it's not Spotify for one
day but and they and all of a sudden
within three hours somebody says the
best album ever oh there's no [ __ ]
way you sat and you listened to every
single [ __ ] one of those tracks and
absorb everything like sonically you did
not pick apart that album to say best
album ever
yeah like jay-z put it the best and this
is when he was he was doing an interview
he was talking about you know before
people were allowed to write an article
about an album yeah they got two weeks
or three weeks before that [ __ ] Rock and
they had to sit in the room and listen
to that [ __ ] exact and then put their
opinion out for sure so now people are
doing this with films and movies because
it's about it's not about quality
content it's about who gets there first
it says their [ __ ] first
wow that's hundred percent right yeah
and because we recognize that like even
with jocks our name isn't so big to the
point where if we did drop an album with
like a collective
that conversation would last maybe three
hours yeah yeah and because we live in
an era right now where works can't
ferment you know like the tomorrow
there's gonna be three other albums and
all these things like this coming out
which is not a bad set let's see what
the streaming service is exactly if you
don't Apple music they're just every
week is just something new new album new
earth so our gameplay is every week just
flooding it with content you know and I
think that way of just dropping new
videos new content and just putting it
out there
I think that's until you know we get our
numbers up and then we get you know a
bigger following I feel like that's the
right thing that's what that one cat
does the one the one cat from Long Beach
was his name from uh stupid young yeah
he crazy yeah yeah I've never seen an
Asian dude drop that many n bombs in my
life and not nobody says [ __ ] to it
saying they should is just more like
that's what he grew up in he's a long
beach [ __ ] and I've never seen I've
never seen another agent get that many
M's either though you know millions he
gets millions of millions shout-out to
stupid yeah that's the authenticity to
like that's what kind of plays I feel
like especially for an agent artist to
come into hip-hop yes we're always gonna
get that scrutiny of the cultural
appropriation and whatnot yeah so that
whole slacktivism air is done you know
like the like like he said to sophomore
jinx is hard because fighting for your
right to be heard as easy the protester
is easy yeah no we're yelling with like
you know trust me we have a voice to
blah blah blah blah we're yellow and
we're proud you know
and then so after we drop seven rings
and we're saying [ __ ] you mean do I
really rap you know we're saying these
things they actually turned their neck
and say okay you got our attention now
what yeah do you know what I mean so
when they do turn your neck when they do
turn the neck and give your attention we
can't follow it out with okay we still
need the right now they're giving us
that window so what are we gonna do we
got to followed up with consistent
persistent quality you know and I and I
say this so much too it's like after you
get that moment of shine you have to
really show people what you're about
because now your little [ __ ] smoke
and mirrors trick me it's done done so
what the [ __ ] are you about now and I
say there's about a lot of like Asian
cats too you keep on [ __ ] doing this
[ __ ] where you're like oh
Asian people need to hear our voice blah
blah blah blah you get that glimpse of
attention now attentions on you show me
what
got right got no skills it's gonna come
out
cream always rises attack there's a lot
of people you need to get you on a track
you're Arab you ever like bro you got
the best name you had a rap name hard
for me because I couldn't was I saying
right so I'm like yeah so I couldn't I
couldn't make it sound not corny you
know I mean cuz I like music so I heard
it and I was like this [ __ ] is trashed
lyrically or like just just lyrically I
couldn't find my flow I couldn't find my
voice so after trying that for a couple
years when I was younger I might this
isn't for me like I can appreciate the
music and I know what I like out of it
right but in terms of me being a rapper
I can parody somebody yes yeah
you know what it means that teracle with
exactly I'm like oh I understand this
flow I'll rap I'll rip this flow and
I'll be fine that's a terrible shitty
show so but other than that I can't I
don't have my own voice in that space
it's too [ __ ] difficult yeah and it's
just like every time I rap I start
talking about food [ __ ] you saying Fat
Boy every song we somehow shout out
Virginia and kimchi jjigae don't know
how that is that's the cool thing though
I think like when I was listening to
especially all the [ __ ] that you droppin
now yeah you guys don't shy away from
who you are
what you'd like and what you do because
there is a space for that right right
and it doesn't sound corny to me which
is so down that's that's the annoying
thing when I hear like people do a song
like big oh do let's make the song
called bobalife why don't you step in
front of a car like [ __ ] man yeah yeah
our recipe is like trying to find that
balance of not neglecting our upbringing
but also not making a gimmick out of it
yes not I mean it's acknowledging the
fact that yeah these are the ways that
we were brought up and these are the
kinds of us like cuz Asians you know in
media after last year with the crazy
rich Asians and all that yeah we're like
a little hotter as far as yeah accepted
wise like so so timing wise for us it's
good thank you already know
yeah but yeah we're just trying to find
a line though we don't want to come out
to too strong with that we don't want to
not represent either I didn't know
Aquafina was was half Korean yes
somebody corrected me I was like no
she's Chinese Korean I'm like no
aquafina has one of those faces were
like certain degree she looks super
Chinese 15 degrees was like oh when I
found out she was Korean I saw her face
she's more influenced with Chinese
because their dad I think raised her and
yeah she's a fellow punch on killer too
she's Korean food like no other yeah
yeah I just I was like I was so shocked
I was like yeah man I thought she was
only Chinese now makes one a rep for
even harder do oh she's half cream I
think I like the morning crazy which
Korean okay do you know what's crazy
about that film and I've always said
this when when this whole like Asian
like Asian film stuff came out then
later oh we got great films - let us
prove it to you Korean people already
proved it what kind of dude I saw the
devil let's go talking about bro let me
tell you something if you guys don't
know any Korean people you love revenge
vengeance the reason why I'm even like
remotely successful is to prove people
wrong that nobody's doubting me I'm just
doubting I'm saying
nobody said you couldn't do it we're
like oh you my manager says he goes who
the [ __ ] like everybody my verse always
ends up like a battle like yo I know you
all these haters like you don't have any
haters I know you mean it but parasite
oh gosh it was incredible Korea is no
drama man we know how to [ __ ] portray
some you know what I love and in what
people don't realize to when they watch
my [ __ ] you see all this comedy it's all
Korean comedy just put English words
right it's all my Korean humor coming
out yeah but people don't know that it's
not on overflow that's where did you get
that would you watch like old Korean
anything really my parents are just
really fun Oh goofy angry people with a
Korean bastard father that's that's the
recipe of man I don't know if I should
tell the story of my mom I get mad oh
sure my mom has like a nasty as far as
[ __ ] lie dude this is only one story
they're like 13 right right so one time
the story rip these nasty ass [ __ ]
she wouldn't even do the courtesy walk
to the back dude she's like she's like
from the Terlato yeah she's a bumpkin
yeah she just like rips his [ __ ] fart
right yeah there's these three customers
in right they come over to the store a
lot I [ __ ] love and the bracele farts
huh [ __ ] was silent she rips what right
and I see her run run towards me
cracking the [ __ ] what are you laughing
at right and then I see this lady she
had so it's three generations a young
little girl in a carriage like in a baby
carriage thing the mom and the grandma
right so and then that she has another
kid so she looks at the little kid so
the the grandma looks at her daughter
right the one that has a case they know
something happens
and then the daughter who's like
whatever in the thirties look at her
other daughter yeah and she goes did you
and she goes I didn't do it it looks at
the little kid look at the carriage and
then a month like no I just changed this
generation a beautiful black woman
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] this
smell is and then my mom's just dying
laughing I'm cracking up too because I'm
not gonna just out my mom in front yeah
but her farts are disgusting it smells
like somebody just [ __ ] on the floor Wow
know why I found out too is because
she's lactose but yeah just to believe
it so that means all their farts is like
passing the tunnel with like poop in it
yeah you know rushing the Korean people
won't believe in just like basic just
science oh yeah I tell them like you're
lactose you you have an allergy to the
the lactose thing right actually goes
that doesn't exist that's [ __ ] funny
cuz your fart just melted my shirt [ __ ]
are you talking about yeah real science
doesn't apply to my parents they're like
yo if you close the door and you have a
fan on you're gonna die oh man I'm like
no no you're not
[Laughter]
every room what are you talking about
right now did your parents ever bust
into your room because kick down my door
because of that do you think they had
like a real-life example or a memory or
anything that came like I don't know
like their friend died or something in
there like oh my god I came in Korea
yeah I sigh me I still don't do it today
just [ __ ] you up the hundred percent
all these like superstitions they lied
to us man don't play with fire you're
gonna pee your pants
you know don't lay down after you eat
you're gonna become a cow we're still
that night snake snakes are gonna come
to you like dude my parachutes do this
[ __ ] to it's funny cuz there's like all
these weird superstitions you know like
you're not supposed to shake your leg
because yeah whatever your luck falls
out so like my I would shake my leg and
then my dad would slap me upside my head
and what are you doing and then he sits
down I see him eating like I'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on right now
Curry's dads are the fire I just she's
are so funny yeah you just watch them
it's funny because like I want to tell
myself I'm not gonna be like that I just
might do it just because it's fun yeah
I'm just on purpose dude I'm gonna tell
them stuff that's clearly not facts and
argue with them just to piss them off
yeah like what you talking about don't
turn the fan dude it's gonna suck out
all the air we're supposed to break the
cycle but I love how you're just like
nah I know we're gonna keep this gonna
keep whatever we can select this is
where the first generation exactly our
parents you know go to heaven nada like
we're gonna there's gonna be no Koreans
like us you know what I think about that
I think about how we're like the we're
like the next wave and so it's our
responsibility to kind of carry on the
like you know drop the fucked-up [ __ ]
and then carry on but you know we got to
carry out if you're the [ __ ] I'm
carrying out a lot of the fucked-up [ __ ]
oh yeah I'm opening up a black beauty
supply store that is going to be zero
profit only to make sure they work it
for ten years that's it then i'ma hire
actors in their face to teach them about
like racial like oh mercy love people
for who they are and not to blame racial
problems on the secular people and then
it's gonna be like The Truman Show or
when they hit 18 by his bunny food
simulation complete
you didn't even know the chandeliers cuz
I just don't want my kids to grow to be
a little [ __ ] man right I'm so scared
cuz I see that in some of my friends
kids we're so spoiled and it's not even
the parents fault
it's just they just have [ __ ] I'm it's a
different it's a different world now do
you know when I sing ology of course
when I see kids under one playing with
an iPad it does something to me I don't
know yeah I know like I I get I'm not in
that position so I could never blame the
parents because I'm sure it's just like
a great distraction unit you know but
you know what it is what I found out
just because I'm seeing my you know yeah
your friends have like one or two year
old true it's because they don't have
that support system like our parents
have with like the honey it's just them
and the kids all the time
where's the budget how many's now
they're still working there's still work
or their day forty their siblings
already has so many kids now it's like
if I give them this iPad for an hour I
get to rest for an hour
yeah before you just give them the
harmonium hydrogen-like right right yeah
toss them away for like a weekend and
then you get that break but you don't
have that now so cuz a lot of these like
first of all these we're having kids
later and later and later the grammars
don't have a lot of energy that is used
to fatigue by then exactly so like for
me I'm just praying that when I do have
a kid my parents have enough energy in
the first six years just to take care of
my kids right gotta toss them away and
want a son first or daughter first
I personally don't give up your gosh I
just want them to be healthy and if it's
a daughter you know you know what knock
on wood yeah but I know this is like
[ __ ] not supposed to be that funny
but it's funny to me
wait wished my if I have a boy he's
gonna be gay only because I want to be
able to like have a great relationship
and just make a bunch of gay jokes and I
don't know but I want is made to be
Korean is funny I want it to be I want
him to understand this culture even if
you don't learn Korean you got a Korean
ass [ __ ] you gotta live with that
growing up there I'm pronounce your name
wrong and all hell yeah dude I give my
kids like hot dogs
what you like my tacos I don't like
talking like this I hope he gets to
bring his boyfriend so I show them a lot
of love too super bad you only give them
penis [ __ ] around like kid like that -
guys I don't want I want I don't want
them to feel like you know my dad's not
gonna joke around with me because he
feels like it's too sensitive but
[ __ ] around with you if you have a
straight brother I'll [ __ ] around with
them too yeah all the [ __ ] time man
don't worry about that [ __ ] I'm excited
man I see I see a lot of my friends
having kids now and you know we have our
generation we have the duality of you
know having two traditional Korean
upbringing and also their Americanized
you know so these kids right now they're
getting best of both worlds but a lot of
the a lot of my friends that are parents
- I see they're still working and
they're still like trying to figure it
out so they just give the iPad to them
you know my prerequisite like even marry
all my fiancee she knows it's like our
kid is has to be fooled in Korean even
if you don't want you could deny your
culture as much as you want that shit's
in your [ __ ] blood yeah yeah yeah and
I want them to have that tool with them
and I want them to understand that
culture is important to me because
people in this country - they think that
for you to be a better American for you
assimilate you have the ratio yeah and I
hate that [ __ ] for sure like I cuz I
grew up I was born in Korea I came in
when I was like 2 or 3 or you're born in
Korea yeah I was a only had a green card
until I was like 22 I'm a rhesus isn't
so yeah you know for me I went to Hong
Kong akio I could read and write and
then apparently I didn't realize how
dated my Korean is because the Korean in
Korea is way different that's exactly me
- I don't make you follow me in jail
right a lot of Korean rest because I
don't know we don't know the slang yeah
yeah it turns out that my dad teaches me
all the Japanese words it washes yeah
yeah they got all this like it's like I
want them to walk away with something
and understand because I think I denied
my Korean is for the longest time until
I got older right as I go I actually
love being worryin man like this is a
huge part of me Mike Mike my comedy my
comedic timing my inner issue
- yeah it's all wrapped up into this
like Korean package and I and I love it
and I want my kids to love that [ __ ] too
so I'm actually kind of happy that I
actually got to fall in love and meet a
Korean woman yeah cuz prior to that it
was only Bennet means a Mexican girls
that's it yes your first Korean girl
second - the one before that was Korean
and now her but before that it was all
Vietnamese in Mexican girls
wow so you speak so fast rhythm is super
fast and they all try to be twisted bro
me now but my brother has kids I have a
older brother two years older my niece
is five and then my nephew's too so like
like I see that cuz my parents they're
living in Virginia Beach with my parents
now so they could use the grandparents
and then yeah how about but the Korean
thing comes up because my mom like gets
mad at us when we talked to the kids in
English mm-hmm she's like yo why you
keep talking in English you have to talk
to them in Korean but we're like yo like
they're gonna go to school they're gonna
learn English you don't done to be
ill-equipped right yeah but my mom only
speaks to the kids in Korean strictly
damn like just so dad somebody's doing
that it was interesting though like what
I've been finding out from a few other
people sighs so when I first came here I
couldn't speak English but my English is
perfectly fine right yes my English is
fantastic yeah my brother came me when
he was five he had to take ESL classes
so school will teach teach English if
you teach them only Korean and they only
know how to speak Korean Atilla 3 or 4
ESL classes will fix all that [ __ ] yeah
like I was I learned Korean first
probably like my greatest recess so I
was speaking Korean before English for
sure yeah sure people get worried about
that part it's like you don't got to
worry about that [ __ ] like like English
is gonna be there I mean see other yeah
you see other kids from different
nationalities they're [ __ ] fine with
that [ __ ] I just I just I just don't
want them to forget that part of them
yeah we don't teach them that they're
gonna forget it unless they seek it out
themselves
later on their own when they're adults I
want to give my kid like they could you
know English my Korean name up until I
got my citizenship is in cooking I mean
go back go back to how you're saying
your timing and how everything is kind
of encompassed in this Korean upbringing
similar with the yaks you know what I
mean when we when we came together we're
like okay let's make this group we
didn't start rapping to become like
forerunners of like this Asian Americans
yeah
movement it wasn't that it wasn't that
but as we get bigger and the mic gets
bigger you know our audience gets more
broad we're like oh there's a deeper
meaning behind us you know there's like
there's people that listen to our music
that are Koreans I don't just like oh
this is good hip hop but they feel
empowered through us you know I mean you
know how they feel like oh there's
someone out there like in the Midwest I
feel outnumbered you know that just feel
like they're not I guess strong or you
know that that's subservient timid
Asians still like there's still that
aura that cloud around them but when
they hear us it kind of gives them that
stim pack you know it kind of gives me
that like that realization like oh you
know what we could do what we want to do
and so when we came together and we
wanted to make a name - we didn't want
to be like ear or the dress you know we
don't be like kimchi or something -
Asiatic but you're the Ox was kind of
like a zodiac
a little Asian as to it and you know and
also it was just everything at like a
rhymes are our verses and all this we we
make people who are Korean feel proud
you know but also we don't make it so
exclusive so that if your non Korean
door like oh these [ __ ] are
just talking about themselves yeah you
know and that balance I mean I have
brought yeah yeah but at the same time
like we we didn't have people like us
growing up especially in hip-hop there's
no Asian rappers we really looked at the
fine thing is one of the DJ doc Jung's
gave it to him yeah yeah like a pajama
even with your [ __ ] David like when when
I remember like your early stuff it was
more like not pg-13 but it was kind of
safer you know and then you got a little
more vulgar with it you were starting
like curse you're starting like getting
more angry and that to me when you made
that transition empowered us because
we're like dude like it was too friendly
like the Asian youtubers it just seemed
like it was too like cushiony you're not
I mean it got to this weird I mean let
me tell you this right now man there's a
lot of youtubers that don't [ __ ] like
me because I have an opinion about [ __ ]
right right
so and I've said there's multiple times
on this podcast but I'll say it again
man just cuz I don't like your [ __ ]
doesn't mean I can't [ __ ] with you as a
person right isn't you can separate the
work into people right and that's no
fault to your own everybody got their
own taste like if I like grape soda
right and you don't like it do I get mad
at you for that [ __ ] and I understand
too because it's like oh this is my art
right right who the [ __ ] cares I as an
artist you put yourself out there to the
public for the people to judge right is
my judge as a listener and a viewer to
see if I like it or not yeah if I don't
like it who the [ __ ] it's a bonus if if
me if I do but people go why don't you
like it it's like dog don't look at me
as David the youtuber I just look at me
in the viewer I'm just a viewer I'm just
a [ __ ] but there are certain youtubers
and you know who the [ __ ] you want
do you care if I like your stuff or not
man I'm a nobody man I'm really a
[ __ ] nobody if I don't like it
guess what there's you're ten times more
popular than I am you're eating good
yeah my shit's not taken away from you
dude so let me dislike your stuff and
they're like well I don't like your
stuff either cool my stuff is good
[ __ ] trash bag I'm just letting you
know right now the acts like we were
thinking about you know how we're doing
weekly drops we're like how do we just
break the internet and one thing we're
gonna do is we've been we've been
holding this in we're just making it dis
song names included just [ __ ] on
everyone we don't leave in my name's
like you know how you did that thing for
dumb Jesus y'all we need that in the
beginning I want that voice clip stuff
like that like kind of you know hip-hop
Scott is competitive you know this rap
game is a sport you know so definitely
right now everyone's just kind of like
it's it's - chinks has to complement
based you know so we definitely want to
make a track like that [ __ ] though I
like the diss tracks don't
when [ __ ] uh when the whole [ __ ]
akashi know when Drake and [ __ ] for
sure oh my god I listen to that track so
many times because dumpee freestyle was
dope yeah we needed the dummy we're like
oh that was nuts and then put yeah do
what he says he's hiding a son I mean
come on dude I'd listen that [ __ ] I was
like dude that was the [ __ ] call this
thing I've ever heard in my life
I'm a funder somebody with multiple
sclerosis but I like that
competitiveness in hip-hop because I
think it brings the best out of people
yeah and every [ __ ] week you know
there's there's a space for this type of
hip-hop right it's not not all hip-hop
has to be there no no no no but when
that [ __ ] happens it makes me feel good
because it shows that people are out
there with their teeth yeah I'm like
yeah it makes me feel [ __ ] gas and
juiced up on my oh [ __ ] come from my era
where the first the line was that's why
[ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
that's more memorable all those times
are more memorable all those beasts that
happen and like yeah
mmm ja rule or that [ __ ] like crazy yeah
but you know them like our idea wasn't
it's not to bully them
you know cuz the first the first track
is is gonna be like you know we shoot
the we shoot the little arrow up there
and if they respond that's that's
interesting you know I want them to
respond is one of those cats too like
I've seen him reinvent himself in the
best type of way man horse battle
rappers that cannot [ __ ] that don't
understand music oh man and he knows
music my favorite battle rappers like
when they you know I'm not a name but
like when they put out the SoundCloud
link and I'd click on I'm like how the
[ __ ] how does that happen like that
internal metronome is wonky in there you
know it's a weird you know what it is
because I think battle rap also to
started steering away from having beat
so now for sure capella know exactly so
they could take their time cause what
sustained pedal for Motta's you know and
you can't you can't do 30 punchlines
within 16 bars it's too much yeah you
gotta set that [ __ ] up it's like
stand-up comedy it's like anything else
that you do you gotta and take them on
that journey take like 500 syllables out
you know yeah for sure I would hear
these [ __ ] these things it's like
dude I don't remember a damn man but you
I'm pretty sure you had hot-ass bars but
it was too much right hold back a little
bit understand the beat like you're not
even they don't even care that about the
beat they just care about that metronome
right you know I mean so they just hear
that but they're not being considered of
them exactly exactly
I'm is a rare one that crossover and
yeah it also makes song to first yeah
for sure
that fools music man when I start listen
to his new [ __ ] like oh he's a music oh
he's good yeah I mean okay blue
for sure you know why it's because he's
not afraid to say like you know the
purist he's like nah I'm looking forward
you know yes he has a foresight that was
my nah my Achilles heel but because I
come from a time where all I preached
was real hip-hop you know so it's kind
of like as like let's say you know like
a past or something that like that like
preach this gospel the whole way and
then like halfway through his life you
realized oh maybe I was wrong you know
maybe there's more to it having the
ability to kind of step aside and humbly
be like you know what maybe let me
revisit one of my philosophy and that
ability to do that is what I had a hard
time doing you know and that was one
thing I needed Jay because when we
became a group like we have two minds
and one and Jay is actually the one like
seven rings the one that popped that
wasn't the style that I wanted to rap on
you know like that would that was
something that would be like nah that's
too like trappy that sounded too like
not you know where's this snare where's
like the DJ premier drum kit you know
and for us to evolve and kind of not
care about what the core audience like
our purest artis a as soon as they hear
a synth or something that's like you
know like the something like yeah Metro
boomin didn't be like yeah that's not
real hit but what they sold out you know
and you see that it not like our drops
but like that's the difference though in
hip-hop with other genres and yeah
hip-hop has so many different variations
now and exactly its form of
like kind of especially in media and
commercials and all that everything like
hip-hop is just there's this weird thing
with hip-hop that I'm not sure people
notices but this was something I was
just thinking about you know like when
you have [ __ ] like um RMB or Rock right
yeah
every RMB or rock artist that comes out
they pay homage the people before for
sure
a lot of these young rappers yes what's
going on because they still pay respect
to the roots and they kind of reformed
their style with hip-hop it's it's
different and I think it makes sense
with hip-hop because it is a lot of like
angst and like [ __ ] you type of [ __ ] for
sure it's gotta be you have to have
originality in some way which is tough
now because hip hop's been around for a
while for sure a lot of things have been
said a lot of styles you know
in defense of these young cats right
it's every generation has that like even
when Ron Kim and Eric became out like
the ones before them were like what is
this you know like they're like what is
this new type of [ __ ] and I think the
reason why I like this new generation
are kind of saying [ __ ] the old heads is
because when that came out the old heads
were the first ones that were bitter and
they were like you know timeout like
yeah daddy if I know this so now they
got so fed up with it that just like now
you know what we're gonna stay on that
ground and that usually happens I think
with anything you know like the new
generation is gonna have to earn their
mark and one thing jail and I were
practicing to be is like we don't want
to be those bitter oh geez you know we
don't want to be the bitter older heads
it'd be like nah dude we want to
actually like collaborate with them
learn from them and kind of you know
give and take because it was hard
because I think there's a lot of people
who were at the forefront of it and
people took their [ __ ] and they got
better from it like for example I've
tried listening to his music as many
times as possible and I just can't like
lil yachty [ __ ] yeah like I'm trying my
best
yeah yeah because I don't want to be
somebody who's gonna hate it just
because it's some new [ __ ] right what
the muffin can't rap like that's what it
is and then he can't sing either and
it's just he's just on this like weird
tip wave but that's why I mean who's
talking about him now right you know
right right so I mean I'm pretty sure
like I'm like I'm he's such a nice dude
too so I'm always rooting for him but
like I said just because I'm moving for
you doesn't mean I don't like your [ __ ]
yeah I just kind of like like that he's
so himself
yeah and I appreciate that so he carved
that exactly that's exactly what it here
to sound like Tamia was a very like
commercial again sounded like he's a
jungle master yeah exactly sure and it's
I look at it like there was an era just
like I think as we come from similar
generation where with these music the
music that these kids were liking even
like the drill stuff in Chicago and all
that
yeah just sounded a little offbeat to me
you know it sounded like it wasn't on
beat yes like the fourth rhyme wasn't it
was it wasn't kicking so in my mind I'm
like dude this is terrible this is trash
right and then I had this moment of a
pit it was like duh the fact that they
don't give a [ __ ] you're not I'm saying
it's not like that punk rock thing even
in the EQ right now before it was like
the pristine cleanliness of the treble
of the bass but right now that rumblings
that the distortion is what's in it's
kind of like that garage that punk rock
feel it's coming backwards like yo real
hip-hop is actually really not
giving a [ __ ] and for the best example
was like there's the double XL freestyle
that happened I mean like yeah d-21
savage all these things yeah when I
first saw that I was like what the [ __ ]
is this trash you know what what is this
this is crazy and now that's one of my
favorite ciphers to watch just because
they're actually freestyling they're
actually having fun you know and it's
the most viewed cipher and there's
numbers don't lie that's crazy cuz I
don't think it's trash but I tried
watching that [ __ ] and I'm like it looks
like a bunch of dumbasses like trying to
rap great but the thing is I feel like
they're trolling I'd be like yeah I know
you think that but like I said I'm not
I'm not like I said I'm trying I'm
trying you know yeah it's just not my my
tastes cuz I do like a lot new hip-hop I
just don't like it that small little
genre is not my [ __ ] right bro that's
why the yeah it's so interesting because
I always listen to your [ __ ] and it's
like you guys are doing a very good job
of staying true to what you're doing
that that old style of hip-hop but it
still has a fresh take on it yeah which
is what I like so I could listen to it
over and over again and it's it's so
it's still catchy right you still have
[ __ ] lyrics to it which I which I do
appreciate and it's people are
recognizing it man not appreciated man
you don't need in my personal opinion I
always say this - it's not about
garnering [ __ ] ten million ten
million people who just randomly listen
exist about that [ __ ] hundred thousand
that [ __ ] you hard right right right
and they'll keep you going and they'll
support you consistently over and over
and over again definitely we definitely
have some some really good supporters
out there right now we're looking for
the archivable recognition you know the
ones like we're ten years down the line
they look at our work and they're like
oh these guys never really shifted you
know like they tried different things
and they experimented but they never
really left they never sold their
integrity you know just to just a catch
of fat or like a trend yeah because you
know when a virus needs a host to live
you know so when a trend is gonna die so
after that trend dies and you went
all-in on this trend and you have to re
you know you have to do all that for us
it's like we we keep our foundation in
our roots but then we'll branch out and
test you know check [ __ ] out who's who's
a like Asian hip-hop artist like a young
younger one coming up that you guys
really [ __ ] with dude there's so many
men like
well they're starting to come out now
like cuz you know we were doing this for
a long time before we was like waiting
for these kids these newer younger kids
to come in but yeah lately now I'm
seeing a lot of guys - yeah go ahead
who do you go I mean before we do that I
have to give a little preface about like
hip-hop to me now right so I came up
with this metaphor about like weed and
hip hop right
there's indica weed and there's sativa
wheat indica weed is like the body high
right it's the in the couch weed which
is like the beets and it's more the puna
gets more the vibe of the song sativas a
mental high where it's like you've
rewind where the metaphors syllables and
all that so before I was a sativa only
hip-hop guy you know but now I'm
starting to appreciate and understand
that as much as conscious rap is amazing
the whole unconscious rap is kind of
cool too you know what I'm talking about
and so like it's fun yeah exactly so
based on those two things I'm not saying
someone's lyrical or not but when it
comes to like the lyrical side of it you
know the Asian guy's like on my East
Coast I had this guy named Cale flows
crazy this guy named will escargot crazy
you know there's people even in Virginia
like my boys see no there's a lot of
people that are like on the lyrical side
but then we also have the pony gear a
pers like little cherry from from New
York she's crazy
you know swim coach really a swim coach
is killing yeah this is a lot of just a
lot of kids right now we're you know
what it is it's like when we were going
up you know how clicked out our skaffa
tyria was yeah as a Korean table black
table but now is United Colors of
Benetton you know it's everything so
like what they think is what we thought
was cool like to them it's you know
we're encyclopedia World Book britannica
babies they're Google calm you know
that's about these kids especially the
ones like if they want to do the
research and learn the history they just
have to look it up yeah whereas you know
we had to actually dig and hey older
brother who would school or whatever but
there's a lot yeah I mean the oxes
mentality and this goes out to anybody
who's really serious about this [ __ ] is
I believe that there was someone half my
age
like in idaho somewhere who's nicer than
me he just doesn't have internet
connection yet you know what I mean
so I got to stay on my toes don't the
day that we think that we're so good and
we're
untouchable by these young cats that's
when we get [ __ ] you know I mean yeah
and I don't know like we treat every
show like there is that like very dojo
man tick window mentality in our in our
in our rats too we treat everything like
a dojo every show that we go to every
every concert we do we think that
there's like the master that stay
watching us you know and we want them to
shudder we want them to be like oh we
can't [ __ ] with these guys that's our
mentality that's really smart it keeps
you guys on your toes under the Sun the
moment you stop being hungry somebody's
gonna take your spot they will that's
the crazy India you know it's crazy they
have in my career you know Tom Bob I was
that rabbit who took a nap and then
whacked tortoises just past me you know
it's having multiple times in my career
so now it's kind of like now I got a
machine I got my brother with me and the
world actually gave me another chance
where people actually give a [ __ ] about
me
I'm not dropping the ball again you know
you know who's really interesting I
don't personally know him but I saw my
doves podcast yeah he's just like a
weird [ __ ] guy that just makes me
laugh like ecstasy yes you would record
of remind me of each other dad
[ __ ] I don't know why it's looking
I'm like yeah it makes me laugh yeah
yeah yeah
and then I don't even know he rapped
know he could [ __ ] rap here too man
yeah I'll make sure that happens to do
he'll be amazing
yes he's one of our closest friends he's
just a good good dude very very
musically talented yeah he's one of my
favorite rappers you know he's a writer
by trade you know you got a school for
writing so see that makes sense now
because I saw if someone's like his
captions you know me like everything is
just he's he's a genius in his own right
and he's another person that's similar
to dumb where he could have he's in New
York you know he's from New Year so you
could have been watch him Berlin yeah he
could have been like you know flushing
all the way yo what up D good he could
do all that but he's identified as an NP
woman wears green and you know that dude
is so [ __ ] odd man like I look at
this [ __ ] I'm like you're weird man
he's what about him I just [ __ ] it I
just want to I just want to shadow him
okay does a kind soul but okay look
right now he's on twitch right now
playing pokemon for the next like 12
hours those [ __ ] he like he'll
just be talking to you like walking down
Cape Town and half let's say ground
floor you'll pick up normal life stories
there were times when he would walk down
Times Square and pick up like large bags
of trash and throw it at people
yes I only know this looks like one of
those wild boys like he's so interesting
looking - he looks is he Korean - yeah
he's Korean no other Korean I've ever
seen in my life
older brother he's so weird yeah shout
out to Ragman so we're looking to have
guys like that like wreck and um you
know Aquafina djs oh we got a got a good
team out here that we just that keeps us
motivated - that's helping us evolve as
artists as well it's really important to
have a strong community around you
especially in this [ __ ] city man
this city [ __ ] chews people up and
[ __ ] spits them back out to right
where they belong oh yeah and it's it's
a [ __ ] scary fact because number one
it's expensive out here you don't know
who your real friends are you have the
people in this city aren't even natives
right right right
and dance room hate the most is like
everybody comes to the city thinking
they have to be something that they're
not yeah you just you just never your
[ __ ] self yeah and so cuz they feel
like they have to smile a little more
they feel like they have to make
everybody their friends they have to be
[ __ ] chummy-chummy yeah right I know
I never get to see who they really are
and so it's it for me like I've never
really connected with too many people
right very cordial you know like I'm
very respectful but then in terms of
like people that I [ __ ] with there's not
that many right right so and that's like
you know I'll reach out like I reached
out to you I reset right then let's get
you on this [ __ ] podcast yeah and so
like if I see like an I mean I'm not a
[ __ ] the gatekeeper but if I if
there's an urgency that I like 1.7
million subs this podcast and I ruined
it all
like yo what'd you do subscribe man let
me do [ __ ] I like please people [ __ ]
with this podcast cuz I think I like
interviewing people that number one like
my fanbase never met before right you
know and there's like a lot of these
real conversations that you don't need
to get the biggest celebrities to have
yes these big celebrity even have
[ __ ] great stories
no not for sure for sure well who came
up with the genius brain work is tight
oh yeah so I hit up this artist in like
I think is like Malaysia Singapore Bravo
got your name - ah - you leave it in the
comments place fire yeah and so I paid
him a grip of money for the [ __ ] I own
the digital rights - everything is so
nice I wanted an art piece versus just a
logo yeah so he did this isometric art
thing and I really [ __ ] with and these
are all the homies in here - are you
speaking about yourself this is you know
nice sarcastic basically it's what you
call someone who's stupid dumb founded
his dumfounded I got it I hated it when
he changed he's always put it on for
like Korean people without having to
shove it in your face yeah yeah I mean
yo I can't indulge too much but he's on
some other [ __ ] right now there's a lot
of ways in the works right now you're
gonna see a lot of him and I can't
[ __ ] wait for a [ __ ] dude this is
always like there's always like these
Asian people that I really [ __ ] with
because I want the people to know you
guys because I want a people to
understand it's just there's more to our
culture than this this [ __ ] geeky
little subset oh yeah and there's a lot
of like [ __ ] youtubers and a lot of
just other new media because like you
know what
god bless your soul right but I don't
want you to represent Asian people
because you make us look so I know
exactly what you mean man there are
a few rappers I mean we will call them
out on the track yeah but definitely
it's like it's not even that I'm mad
that they're wack
it's just yo like you know that it's
lackluster you know it's a little
shingle and you know it like you're
you're being late werster they don't
know it don't ya but I mean that's why
we're here you know that's you gotta
flush Madeleine's
you know I love that [ __ ] yeah I feel my
Korean soul burning inside 50 cent how
to rob coming soon yeah that's what I'm
saying - and it's like I don't he the
thing I don't like it is when a lot of
certain Asian American people and I
could say this about our culture it's
like yeah if you haven't done [ __ ] don't
expect the respect that you're that you
feel like it's desert to you you shut
the [ __ ] up and do something first and
then you'll get that due respect right
and that's the problem it's like oh why
don't people respect me more as a
prominent Asian you know cuz you're
[ __ ] trash mesm that's why don't
expect people just to respect you for
what for what why cuz you did a couple
of viral video right [ __ ] that [ __ ] do
say something about yourself like
similar to how I mean not to get too
deep but like you know how some
religions they until persecution happens
like that religion is not strong you
know you have persecution and same thing
with uh with art I feel like especially
if you're Korean or you're Asian
the moment that we get to dis our our
works within each other that's progress
yeah you see I'm saying like when
everything is just like a town the
better oh that I get it just I get to
know like they giving leeway to each
other because we're Asian that's gonna
keep us at this level as I said when
crazy rich Asians came out yeah I bought
a few tickets yeah I didn't go see the
movie cuz I knew I wasn't gonna like it
right and then some people were mad
they're like welcome you do not that was
one of the best movies I was like first
of all don't tell me what I think is the
best move yet personal preference yeah I
don't like rom-coms so I'm already not
gonna like it right but I'm where to put
my money and support it so I'll support
the [ __ ] for sure but I'm still
allowed to have my opinion on whether I
like it or not
why can't I say that I dislike something
yeah you know yeah because it's
completely okay I'm still gonna support
it because I understand we're at a
disadvantage right now in terms of like
that type of media but when when like I
said what like you said to when
everything's out and things are good
guess how much [ __ ] I'm going to talk
finally we're making we have so many
Asian American representation now cool
well your [ __ ] [ __ ] suck that [ __ ]
was trash I [ __ ] hate all that [ __ ]
but I'm proud we're here that's the
reason why Jax and David so [ __ ] like
this is necessary is because unless we
do something about it we're always gonna
have this conversation where I asked my
friend I'm like who's your favorite
rapper and you'd be like like a real
rapper an Asian rapper yeah podcaster
you like oh you mean like a real podcast
or like a you know one of my ancient pot
it's like we're trying to get rid of
that pressure which I gave her that
prefix no this close to calling this
podcast by the way that like okay like I
let you know Justin's crazy that was
very stylized for me was a very artsy
film but the fact that he didn't show
anything about that riots but they would
still yeah understood it was there and
like you you completely stripped it was
like the punch-drunk love like Adam
Sandler like yeah you went complete
serious on it that [ __ ] was right yeah
man because that was a huge portion of
my life growing up so if you were here
during the riots I wasn't here during
the ride like that whole you know just
like the Asian black community right
that is my take on good tell yeah
there's like a lot of Korean rage and
they're that silly and father-to-son
right because like Justin kind of played
more of my father figure he's like
you're laughing at all the [ __ ] that I'm
doing but you know he still wants to
support me and he still wants to love me
so it was more like a father to son
you're like the eazy-e
and it was it was that film to like I
don't know if I'll ever do my own film
again like that but it was good to know
that I did something that I think it
spoke to a lot of people for sure and so
for me like I could die happy with that
like I don't have to go to the the crazy
Hollywood route if it happens it happens
yeah I just know I made a statement
piece for people know yeah you know good
you capsulated the perfect and I'm so
happy you didn't turn turn this into
goop podcast yeah and it was gonna be
literally a Cookie Monster but he has
gonna call Cookie Monster's that's what
it was supposed to be but then you know
through conversation they're like I made
it and I was like it would still would
have been great through a conversation
it's funny for a little bit but after a
while so it makes sense do you guys want
to like promote any [ __ ] right now
before we [ __ ] close this pocket talk
to you guys for another five good man I
mean we just dropped another video
tonight when is this gonna [ __ ] you are
right I could release it as soon as you
guys well I could release this next
Sunday if you want yeah well yeah okay
well next Sunday we're gonna have
another video we can by force last year
to Ox yup officially ox on instagrams a
forward slash right now isn't it no no
is it back slash four slash anyway yeah
who gives a [ __ ] point is at official
yaks on IG at yaks underscore jail at
underscore max underscore Rick you know
that's our Instagram handles official
yaks calm yeah just check assemble your
dogs subscribe because we're an active
youtube channel like every Friday at
6:00 p.m. you're gonna hear the
notification ding because religiously
we're just gonna we're gonna drop it for
you guys you know so thank you man
that's dope man check them out man
listen to some really good hip-hop and
then you know support the people that I
support because I'm trying to [ __ ]
make sure dope people are doing well and
why people windows would be the focus
but really build the whack people I
actually do this because I want you to
become better I love how you tied it to
like the the beatings also trying to
like get you to be on a good level dude
yeah I do this out of love dude it's
supposed to be more than it hurts you
catch us on Spotify stitcher any type of
audio platform yes in Thursday's you
know what it is GX that's that piece